flying over monster airport
row after row of lorries creeping ever
further down this now disused runway
this was early morning and as the day
progressed
many more vehicles ended up here
around 700 others were parked up in the
m20
ignoring official warnings not to travel
to channel ports
mayor's law from poland has been here
since the weekend
stranded and now fast running out of
supplies
this is freezer my freezer
my food is almost finished
the road holiers association says
authorities
are vastly under reporting the number of
lorries
now stuck in kent they estimate at least
4 000
and growing and these images we captured
on roads
around the county would appear to back
that up
hundreds of lorries and vans parked up
in every lay-by
this is the a-2 they're not just crammed
in lay-bys
but also on slip roads and around
roundabouts
and the closer you get to the port such
as dover itself
it's even worse these are quite
incredible scenes on almost every street
in dover
you're greeted with this row after row
of lorries
vans and cars all trying to make it
across the channel and despite being
urged to move on
those i've spoken to say they're going
nowhere
mixed in with the many hollyers are
those just trying to get back to their
families
like this busload of moldovans who've
been working on construction projects in
the uk
and stranded here for two days it's so
frustrating this
situation because
unfortunately we didn't know nothing
when we wasn't away here
the introduction of rapid and accurate
covet testing
has always been the key to persuading
the french to open up their ports again
the transport secretary says agreement
has been reached with france
and traffic should start flowing again
soon
we have managed to get all those tests
to uh
kent enough for all the vehicles which
will want to return before christmas so
that won't be an issue obviously there's
a physical issue of
uh you know providing the test getting
the results
and negative tests allows you to leave
but
all of that requires operationalizing
and
that can't happen in an instant so this
will take
two or three days for things to be
cleared
but at manston airport patience is
wearing thin
those tests can't come quick enough for
these drivers
[Music]
it has been a grim few days but some at
least
are trying their best to keep up the
christmas spirit
merry christmas mark white sky news
dover